بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
الله اكبر الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان لا
اله
الا
اشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله
اشهد ان
محمدا
رسول
الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على
[Silence]
حي على الفلاح
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله
الا الله
الله
اللهم
الحمد لله
الحمد لله نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره ونعوذ
بالله من شرور انفسنا ومن سيئات اعمالنا
من يهدي الله فلا مضل له ومن يضلل فلا
هادي له واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا
شريك شريك له واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
صفي خلقه وحبيبه بلغ الرساله وادى الامانه
ونسحى الامه وكشف الله تعالى به الامه
وجاهد في الله حق جهاد حتى ات اليقين اما
بعد فقال الله سبحانه وتعالى في القران
المجيد فرقان الحميد بعد قعوذ بالله من
الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يا
ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته ولا
تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون ثم اما بعد ان
اصدق الكتاب كتاب الله تعالى وخير هدي هدي
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم وشر الامور
محدثتها وكل محدثه بدعه وكل بدعه ضلاله
وكل ضلاله في النار ربي اشرح لي صدري ويسر
لي امري واحلل عقده من لساني يفقه قولي
اللهم لا سحل الا ما جعلته سحلا وانت تجعل
الحزن اذا شئت سحلا ولا حول ولا قوه الا
بالله العلي العظيم الله ربنا وثقتنا
ورجاؤنا ومولانا فنعم المولى ونعم النصير
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏alles
and everything
[Silence]
‏alles
weقم
to house him
all
mery ‏choes from his creation what he
wishes. There is no adjusting of his
judgment and turning away from his
decree. He is not asked what he does and
people will be asked for what they do.
Glory to be him he has made in the
alteration of the days and the nights a
lesson for the believers. In the success
of the days are signs for those who
truly choose to reflect on Allah's
creation. ‏Seasons hardly end until
another follows it and the opportunity
for goodness barely finishes until
another one appears and we have just
to a 1446 the year had concluded and it
just feels a blink of an eye when
the year started and we have entered the
that means that we have been further
away from the
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الحج
الله
محرم منطف محرم
رحمه الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله
present
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم ابراهيم عليه
الصلاه والسلام اسحاق عليه الصلاه والسلام
يعقوب عليه الصلاه والسلام
other props forb
himself the house
that is الم and the
محم is from mon and the
الحسن رحمه
‏almighty
‏and
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتعالى سوره توبه ان عده شهور
عند الله 12 شهرا في كتاب الله يوم خلق
سماوات والارض منهم اربعه حرم ذلك الدين
القيم فلا تذنوا فيهن انفسكم
صدق الله العظيم
الله
do not
القبي
الله interation ofرانes
mon for
in even though is all time so we not
just these months are prohibited that we
can do nothing wrong but Allah has
prohibited in all the months but these
months are mentioned with more stress
and moreousness by Allah subhanah wa
‏us and
fasting
this beautiful month and the of fast
ofanيره
رضي الله عنه رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم منشن افضل الصيام بعد رمضان شهر شهر
الله المحرم وافضل صلاه بعد فريضه صلاه
صلاه الليل رواه مسلم اقما قال عليه
الصلاه والسلام
صحيحم
مسلميره
الله رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
المحرم
التهجد
point
first and
الله سبحانه وتالى
first
صلاه
‏states month for
the fast is the best beginning of the
year and is open with fasting which is
the best of the deeds and based on the
had the best deeds that musl can perform
in the month of is fasting first and for
so musl do a lot of volunary fasting in
it and let us remember that fasting has
virtues and greater reward with الله
سبحانه وتعالى
سهل بن ابن سعد بنير رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم ان في الجنه با قال له الريئان
الريئان يدخل من السائمون يوم القيامه لا
يدخل منهم احد غيرهم يقال اين السائمون
فيقومون لا يدخل منهم احد غيرهم فاذا
دخلوا اغلق فلم يدخل منه احدا او كما قال
عليه الصلاه والسلام
مسلم
رسول الله صلى الله عليه
‏in parad
which only those who have fastenture
and on the and no else and the door will
call out those who have fasted
where are the people who fasted for the
sake of Allah and once they enter
through the gate the gate will close
forever and it will not be open for
anybody except for the
ابو سعيد رضي الله عنه رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلمشن
ما من عبد يصوم يوما في سبيل الله الا بعد
الله بذلك يوم وجهه عن النار 70 خليفه او
كما قال عليه الصلاه والسلام
سن النساء
رسول الله صلى الله عليه
رضي الله عنه
الله
70 years
from
one day of fasting put a distance of 70
years 7
between us and
الامام البحي رضي الله عنه منشد
اس رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم صحابي
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم يا رسول
الله امرني بامر ينفع ينفعني الله
الله
فقال عن رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
عليك بالصيام
فانه لا مثل له او كما قال عليه الصلاه
والسلام رسول الله صلى الله عليه
‏for you is to
myation you because other
so in monoc
first and for
make
‏are tak care ofocus
for
which is
in this
and make Allah
the first
you isful
الله سبحانه
بحانه
over
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
بحانه وى
body
has been given by Allah and such has to
back
just not here ‏to wake up go to jobs pay
bills and die one day
we have other obligations that need to
be fulfilled and connected I ask Allah
in this beautiful month he makes us to
return to him in a beautiful way and not
a way and that he cleanses our hearts
for each other first and forem and for
the nation over and he connects us each
other with the clean heart as a true
brother
الله صلى الله
[Silence]
سبحانه وتعالى الله سبحانه وتعالى الحديث
القدسي ارحم من في الارض من السماء
اقول ما تسمعون استغفر استغفر الله لي
ولكمسائ المسلمين فاستغفر الغفور الرحيم
الحمد لله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
10 محرم الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏to tr
عليه
as him
and his people the false
and his people and the victory is still
a matter of consideration and
appreciation till today so for us to
fast day out of greatness for الله
سبحانه وتالى الله
سبحانه وتعالى
النور وعد الله الذين امنوا منكم وعملوا
الصالحات
ليستغفرنهم في الارض كما استغفر الذين
استغفر الذين من قبلهم
‏am
[Silence]
بعد ذكر ان الارض يثباد الصالحون
‏And we have written in the book of the
previous mentions the land is inherited
by the sermons only also there's a great
reward and goodness in fasting this day
for it expates the sins minor sins of
the year previous year and not the major
sins. It's a difference of opinion among
some scholars that the minor sin are
forgiven and the major sins are not
forgiven.
ابو قاده رضي الله عنه منش رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم وصيام يوم عاشو احتسب الله
على الله ان يكفر السنه التي قبلها
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وتعالى
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
العاشوره ابن عباس رضي الله عنه ما رايت
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم يتحرى صيام يوم
فضله على غيره الا هذا اليوم يوم العاشور
وهذا شهر يعني شهر رمضان
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم رسول الله
صلى الله عليه
‏more any other was
month that was for
the sched
and not
صلى الله عليه وسلم
عاش
محرم ابن عباس
الله رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم عاشور
يا رسول
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم يا رسول
الله انه يذارى
يا رسول الله
عاشور
فقال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلمذا
كان المقبل ان شاء الله
انء ‏will days one day increase one more
right and ination mention that they came
toas said you know the fasting of
the day of atonement
and if not known as for the Jewish
tradition it's a day of fasting for the
Jews and the Christians because they
celebrate
the deliverance of of ‏the children of
Israel from Phara
and away from it and he said look me and
Musa are brothers
right me and him are brotherhood of the
prophets and as such we honor him Allah
had honored him that day with
deliverance and we honor that day by
fasting that day so more the fast
ابن تيميه معك
صلاه المستقيم الامام احمد رحمه الله
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى
ان الله
mention
انء الله تعالى
ان 10
انء
الله
هذه وصلوا وسلموا على نبيكم كما امركم
بذلك ربكم فقال ان الله وملائكه هلم على
النبي يا ايها الذين امنوا صلوا عليه
وسلموا تسليما اللهم اهنا في من هديت
وعافنا في من عافيت وتولنا فيليت وباركنا
فيما اعطيت وكنا شر ما قضيت ان تقضي ولا
يقضى عليك انه لا يذل ما واليت ولا يعز من
عاديت تبارك ربنا عليك اللهم اسك من خير
كل عاجله واجله وما ما علمنا منه وما لم
نعلم ونعوذ بك من شر كله عاجله واجله وما
علمنا منه وما لم نعلم
اللهم نسالك بخير ما سالك عبدك نبيك ونعوذ
بك من شر ما عاد به عبدك ونبيك اللهم
نسالك الجنه وما قرب اليه من قول وعمل
ونعوذ بك من النار ما قرب اليه من قول
وعمل نسالك ان تجعل كل قضيه خيرا
عباد الله ان الله يامر بالعدل والاحسان
وتائذي القربى ويرحم فحشاء منكر بغي
يعيذكم لعلكم تذكرون اذكروا الله العظيم
اذكركم
نشكره نستغفره يغفر لكم واتقوه يجعل لكم
من امركم مخرجا وقيموا الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله
حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد قامت الصلاه قد قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر
لا اله الا الله
محمد رسول الله صل على اللهم صل على وبارك
‏is on the behind and automatically
shoulders pleas don't spaces
from الله سبحانه وتالى
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله
سبح اسم ربك الاعلى
الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى
والذي اخرج المرعى
فجعله غثاء
احوى
سنقرئك فلا انسان
الا ما شاء
الله
انه يعلم الجهر وما يخفى
ونيسرك لليسرى
فذكر ان نفعت الذكرى
سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها
الاش
الذي يصلى النار الكبرى
ثم
لا يموت فيها ولا يحيا
قد افلح من
تزكى
وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى
بل تؤثرون
الحياه الدنيا
والاخره
خير
وابقى
ان هذا لفي الصحف الاولى
صحف ابراهيم
وموسى
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
ايا اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
الله
والتين والزيتون
وكورسين
وهذا البلد الامين
لقد خلقنا الانسان
في احسن تقويم
ثم رددناه اسفل سافلين
الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات فلهم اجر
غير ممنون
فما يكذبك بعد بالدين
اليس الله
باحكام
الحاكمين
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اشهد ان
صل اللهم صل على
صل
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد
السلام عليكملام
first
‏Pleas take
them and
we have the
in this and we need your children to
join us for
is taking care of these matters and we
need lots of your children to that you
can help
‏So this is the time to teach the basic
and fundamental things andally to sch
this is and sister again
we have announ but i don't think the g
out yet so pleas if can the seats in
that sch
lonely
generously on